Hey, everyone. Rawkode here. I
just wanna take a minute to show off
a couple of the latest pull requests that
have been merged into Kubernetes master,
to pull requests that have been a long
time coming and solve some really
common problems that you'll have when working with
kubectl on the command line.
So first of all, what I'm gonna do
is take a look at this really simple
deployment I have here.
It's deploying five replicas running Apache.
We're gonna apply that to our cluster.
We do a watch and just wait for
those to become running.
Almost there.
A very common thing that you're gonna have
to do is get the logs from one
of your containers.
And today, we do that with dash logs
and you guess which one you think might
have the log that you're actually looking for.
And I'm assuming
at some point you may have tried
to do this.
So using the label selector to try and
fetch the logs from multiple pods where the
app equals h t t p d and
follow them along at the same time.
And that doesn't work. We can't run both
of these together and that was until a
couple of days ago.
So if we use kubectl master, which I've
built from source,
run logs,
use the label selector
and follow,
I can now follow the live logs from
all of the pods in that deployment,
and that is awesome.
Great work to the people that worked on
that.
The other thing that I wanna show off
now is customize,
which is now baked into kubectl as well.
So if I take a look at the
tree here, you can see I have a
base and a prod directory.
Instead of base, we've got a deployment dot
yaml and a customization dot yaml. Inside prod,
we have just a customization dot YAML.
If we take a quick look at base
and our deployment,
it's deploying NGINX,
nothing fancy there, there's no namespace specified in
the metadata
and if we take a look at our
customization dot yaml you can see that we
are targeting that deployment dot yaml only this
time we're gonna add a couple of couple
of labels and we're gonna enforce a namespace.
If I do cube control master
apply
dash k and specify the base directory, the
dash k means that we want to deploy
a customization directory or a customized directory.
Now, the namespace doesn't exist, so right, we
can quickly create that.
And now, we can apply again and we
get our deployment.
I'll clear the deployments,
Kubernetes,
we can see my app there. So although
the namespace wasn't specified and the manifest itself
is applied through customize
and if we do some content negotiation on
the desk,
we will also see
our labels have been applied to.
One more example of this is now I
can run apply dash k on prod,
which is gonna fail because of the namespace
again.
Run that again and now my deployment using
the exact same manifest
is in the production namespace.
So that's it for this episode. Thank you
very much for tuning in. I hope you
enjoy these new features. Thank you everyone that's
built them, merged them and contributed in some
way. These are awesome and I can't wait
to use these at all my future scripts.
Thanks.